what could I get here sunny Milo - this
is the update of the my loved one which
was a pretty kick-ass device this device
also kicks ass first of all it's got
Skype on it so you can just sync it up
with the internet make Skype phone calls
second of all it's got a web browser on
it and Wi-Fi so you can get on the
Internet
I am your friends when you're not
skyping them get a really really cool
thing about this is it's got a
touchscreen on it so you can just look
whatever you like on the screen now
using the QWERTY keyboard what it
doesn't have cell phone and we told Sony
about this and they just kind of give
some blank stares but we don't really
care because it's
Oh 108 inch LCD from sharp I've seen
bigger than that
whoa you might think this is some sort
of like creepy NSA ban out to Robbie
who's your constitutional rights and spy
on you but it's not it's actually a van
from tele Atlas which is a company that
does digital mapping for GPS units and
other online services just between you
me though kind of freaks me out still
hear that that's the sound of progress
it's also the sound of the Samsung HDX
810 it's a virtual surround sound bar
that has virtual 5.1 surround sound as
well as a 1080p upscaler as well has the
ability to sync up with that little
subwoofer there in the corner via
bluetooth so you kind of put it anywhere
you want your house and you're not gonna
trip over any course it's really cool
it's really loud and I can't wait to get
one for my small studio apartment
this is an iPhone but this isn't our
Monty phone maybe by Samsung Giorgio
Armani he's got a touchscreen like an
iPhone
he's got twice as many buttons as an
iPhone but brother
this ain't no iPhone it's smaller
lighter and we look better looking
actually not available in the United
States yet and it used to yes em so if
you have a CDMA or Sprint or something
you're not gonna be able to transfer
over to it but it is really cool
they'll set you back about 800 euros you
have to look for it online first though
Giorgio Armani he'd like his Cologne
love this phone
you